[Musique]
l'anonymat absolu ça n'existe pas parce
que on a toujours des traces sur
internet quelles que soient ses traces
et quelles que soient les moteurs de
recherche
donc en effet c'est une question mais je
pense que la vraie question c'est plutôt
la question du pseudonymat pour moi
l'anonymat est un principe général sur
le net comme dehors on doit pouvoir être
à ali c'est un des fondements ya
démocratie de manière générale était
démocratie numérique en particulier et
tout problème c'est de trouver un
équilibre entre le droit à l'anonymat et
la protection des victimes
aujourd'hui le cadre juridique quelques
il existe mille sans fatigue organisé
cet équilibre c'est plutôt un difficile
non pas des droits mais d'application
des règlements et pour la petite
dynamisation stricto sensu je pense que
ça doit être un droit fondamental qu'il
faut qu'il faut préserver tout en
trouvant une solution pour protéger les
victimes
la démocratie c'est pas non plus le
droit de tout dire n'importe quoi et des
avoirs des propos haineux et dénigrant
et se cacher derrière une fausse
identité
donc on a vu les abus récemment
donc on a des moyens juridiques bien sûr
il ya tout un arsenal juridique existe
pour les rechercher
mais à l'heure actuelle où il ya une
communication de masse il faut aller
plus loin
ce qu'il faut c'est augmenter les
sanctions des personnes en avant des
personnes que ce soit des sanctions
civiles et extensions pénale il faut
protéger les victimes donc le droit
n'est pas à modifier de son côté sur la
liberté dans l'anonymat
sur les plateformes tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire une régulation
a priori pour effectivement les v4 est
extrêmement rare et une régulation sur
une notification pour les autres cas
mais il faut protéger les victimes 3 8x
et leur donner des droits et ce n'est
pas porter atteinte aux libertés qu'on
protège les victimes
c'est un mouvement dont leurs droits
leur capacité à les mettre en oeuvre le
financement de leurs droits en
permettant par exemple à des
associations d'agir encore que
rapidement et le lever l'anonymat
quasiment instantanément lorsque une
personne fait état de sa situation
victimes se réservent elles mêmes la
disparue mais finalement c'est le droit
des victimes qu'il faut renforcer et non
pas les droits des libertés qu'il faut
militer
on n'est pas obligé forcément de
rajouter des textes parce qu'il ya un
arsenal juridique assez ample aussi bien
au niveau national qu'au niveau européen
il faut renforcer les moyens de l'état
notamment sur la plateforme pharos
il faut aussi rempli renforcer les
moyens de poursuite de ces individus
tout en gardons bien sûr le libre jeu de
l'exercice de la liberté d'expression et
d'opinion
on est libre de ce qu'on publie mais si
on est libre on à la conséquence de la
responsabilité on est libre et
responsable parce que on le consent
alors c'est pas simple mais je pense que
on en a les moyens
aussi bien technique que juridique on
s'aime 2 est vraiment s'intéresser aux
plateformes pas ce que je fais c'est là
que se situe
pour d'articulation entre liberté
d'expression protection des victimes
c'est l'obligation de vérifier
l'identité l'identité de la personne
elle même vis-à-vis de l'audience mais
qu'elle est parfaitement personnalisé
vis-à-vis de la plate forme pour que
celle ci puisse révéler cette identité
en cas de drame d'haïti la liberté
d'expression suppose qu'il n'y ait pas
un système d'auto censure par des
algorithmes mars qui vont définir
effectivement des rêves minimisation de
la liberté d'expression et de marc plus
qu'un discours uni c'était un discours
minimalisme qui risque d'être arrivé si
on permet effectivement les
intelligences artificielles de lutter
contre toute forme effectivement
d'expression et vue mais qui les porta à
savoir des victimes et je rejoins la
crainte de mon confrère sur une société
panoptique où finalement on aurait le
droit que de ce que de dire que ce que
nous présente l'ordinateur et les
algorithmes
donc faisons attention n'ayons pas peur
de nos propres opinions
dès lors qu bien sûr elles respectent
tous les droits précédent donc un de ne
pas nuire ne pas dénigrer ne pas être
raciste de xénophobe faut revenir bien
sûr principes fondamentaux de la charte
européenne des droits de l'homme et puis
évidemment contrôle et contrôler cet
exercice surtout contrôler les
algorithmes et la société al à l'heure
actuelle convient dans laquelle on vit
évidemment nous pousse à nous interroger
sur l'île at il vraiment une place pour
un débat sain et claire et accepter
l'autre tel qu'il est avec sa différence
d'opinion c'est quand même très
compliqué une fois avouez quand même que
c'est très compliqué et qu'on nous
pousse vers des extrêmes
alors est ce que ce sont là est ce que
c'est la faute des algorithmes à ce que
c'est la faute des plateformes je vais
pas c'est pas le propos aujourd'hui mais
il faut en être conscient il faut faire
attention il faut lutter pour maintenir
cette liberté d'expression dans le cadre
légal qui est le nôtre